Speaker 1: Let's follow up about school lunch.
This story is just vile. We've talked about
Republicans and school lunch before. The
news is that Mitch McConnell is reportedly
again opposing free school lunch. The Washington
Post reports that Mitch McConnell is opposing an
extension to the free school lunch program. This
comes as Congress is deciding what to include in
the upcoming government funding package. You may
recall that again, we are in the situation where
the Free School Lunch, the Comprehensive Free
School Lunch program that was started and expanded
during the pandemic, has an expiration date
on it. And now there are Republican lawmakers,
including Mitch McConnell, who oppose including
that in a new government funding package.
I have to tell you that this is one of the most
vile things like you really have to understand
the degree to which these people cannot empathize
with anybody else. And we've talked about
opposition to free school lunch from the right
wing before. Remember this clip from October,
where Fox News anchor Martha MacCallum is like,
Listen, if kids think school lunch is free, then
I guess something very bad would happen.
Speaker 2: One of the things that kills me
is that now that you know, there's a free lunch
program in New Jersey and it's for everyone,
even if you you don't need help to send your
child's lunch to school. So those kids are
all going to grow up thinking what school is for
lunch is free, right? And then God help the person
who comes along and tries to take that away.
Speaker 1: Like these kids might grow up thinking
school lunch is free. And why shouldn't it be?
Why shouldn't it be in a literal sense? Of course,
food's not free. You understand this. I understand
this. It's, you know, people pay property taxes
and it funds schools and you're paying for
school lunch. Sometimes property taxes include
trash pick up. The trash pickup isn't literally
free. It's paid for through your property tax.
OK. Sometimes. It's good when we pay for things
with taxes, and sometimes it's not so good. So,
for example, many of us would say, I don't love
that my taxes without any option. I mean, OK,
you know, we could replace everybody to and
the military industrial complex and only elect
people who won't support it in any way. It's not
realistic that that's going to happen overnight.
I don't necessarily love tax money going to some
of the weapons that it goes towards. OK, fine.
When we're talking about school lunch, first
of all, it's so cheap. It's so cheap. Secondly,
it's really stigmatizing. A lot of schools still
have this colored lunch ticket program at my
elementary school. You know, 90 years ago, if you
paid full price for lunch, you got a green ticket.
And if you got the discounted lunch, you got a
yellow ticket. And if you got free lunch, you had
I think it was like a red ticket or whatever.
It's extraordinarily stigmatizing to do that
in elementary schools in a way that can be really
damaging to kids. And when they say, you know, we
can't have kids growing up thinking that it's
free if property taxes cover school lunch,
what's the big, devastating realization
that kids will come to? It's just,
oh, the lunch is free. We pay for it through
property taxes. All right. Well, I understand it.
School is mandatory. You have to be there, but
they don't have to give you food at no additional
cost. At the point of purchase, you have to
be there and your property taxes pay for it.
There are kids, depending on the school lunch, in
order to eat. And Republicans don't want to do it
either because they say we can't afford it
because we obviously can, or because they
think that children are going to be taught some
bad lesson. Is it a good thing to be thinking that
if you're a kid in school to be thinking that
whether I eat depends on anything other than just,
am I here? Can my parents afford it or not? Did
Mitch McConnell extend the program or not? Or
will you get lunch and you don't? It's absurd.
It's absurd. And of course, it's not even really
free. It's just prepaid. That's really all that
we're talking about. And when you step back,
if you are a politician and you think
so-called free school lunch is a problem,
then you're not even in the right universe. You're
not even in the right galaxy when thinking about
the problems that we have. And Mitch McConnell now
joining the train in saying, No, no, no, no, no.
We can't allow this to happen. School lunch
should just be free period and by free, I mean,
prepaid through property taxes as it already is,
but for everybody rather than just some people.